[Applause]
early morning gunfire echoes across the
stretch of the salwyn river along the
border between myanmar
and thailand this video from the thai
side appears to show korean national
union fighters
taking over a myanmar army outpost then
burning it to the ground
it's some of the most intense fighting
between ethnic armies and myanmar's
military since the coup
nearly three months ago the corrin
fighters are one of about two dozen
ethnic minority forces that have been
fighting the myanmar military for
decades
seeking greater autonomy like the korean
rebels many of them have thrown their
support behind the antiku protest
movement that has swept across myanmar
since the takeover
there has been talk about forming a
federal army
some feel the attack on the outpost was
a signal from the korean national union
to myanmar's army
locally known as the tapidon and this
shows that we have a plan in our area
to diminish your territory and take over
more of what we see as our territory
but also do it at a moment that
discredits the power of the tamil
um and which gives a symbolic boost i
think
uh to broader nationwide um uh
resistance against against the military
so it's it's it's a lot of different
things all wrapped up together
he went on to say that a strong
retaliation is expected
air strikes from the military on current
held territory have increased over the
last few weeks
at one point sending hundreds across the
border into thailand
seeking refuge and medical attention 24
000 people have been displaced since
late last month according to korean
groups
also on tuesday the military junta said
it will consider suggestions
on how to end the crisis in myanmar made
by the southeast asia regional bloc
asean in a saturday meeting the
announcement could be viewed as a
setback since leaders said a consensus
was already reached with ajunta on steps
to end the violence
some protesters are taking their battle
against the junta from the streets to
the jungle
this footage appears to show a training
camp run by ethnic armies
preparing those who want to transition
from protester to fighter
while there are still protesters
dedicated to taking their call for the
junta to step down
to the streets but in smaller numbers
because of the intensified crackdown by
security forces
making sure their voices are heard scott
heidler al jazeera
bangkok